eca danièle obono député la france
insoumise de la dix septième
circonscription de parry bonsoir danièle
obono merci d'être avec nous votre
réaction à ce discours d' emmanuel
macron ce soir écoutez c'est un discours
qui a donné une date
donc c'est un horizon une perspective de
sortie du confinement mais n'a pas
vraiment explicite et les moyens qui
étaient prévus et la quantité de moyens
qu'il faudrait pour pouvoir réaliser ce
déconfinement on se pose encore plus de
questions de mon point de vue et nous
aurons beaucoup de questions à poser aux
gouvernements et des propositions à
faire sur la manière dont nous pensons
qu'il est nécessaire d'organiser la
production de la planifier pour être en
capacité de procéder à un déconfinement
qui ne peut être de notre point de vue
que progressif et ciblé parce que en
l'état étant donné les retards qui ont
été pris pour prendre les mesures de
protection étant données y compris la
manière dont le confinement actuelle est
organisée c'est à dire qu'il ya malgré
ce qu'a dit le président qui parlait
d'un confinement strict il y a beaucoup
de secteurs non essentiels qui sont
encore en activité que le gouvernement a
poussé à continuer à être en activité
sans que les salariés de ces secteurs
soient suffisamment protégé il y a au
niveau de la santé il l'a reconnu
d'ailleurs le président beaucoup de
soignants et soignante qui n'ont même
pas encore les moyens de protection donc
déjà en confinement il y as on voit bien
des problèmes en terme de production de
tests suffisant production de masse et
de l'ensemble des matériels de
protection donc de notre point de vue
d'une certaine manière le gouvernement
prend là peut-être encore les choses à
l'envers
il s'agit de déterminer quels sont les
besoins pour pouvoir protéger l'ensemble
de la population
et ensuite comment est-ce qu'on organise
la production la société pour le faire
donc il y à une date encore une fois un
11 mai et on va voir un peu c'est un
rétroplanning qui qui qui est présentée
puisque nous aurons cette fin de semaine
à l'assemblée des premiers éléments de
deux de moyens financiers est ce que par
exemple le gouvernement va enfin accéder
à notre proposition de ré institutions
de liesse pour permettre de mettre en
oeuvre la production suffisante
est-ce qu'il va accéder à notre
proposition de réquisition d'un certain
nombre d'industries notamment
l'industrie textile pour pouvoir
produire autant de max que possible au
niveau national localement et pas
simplement attendre les importations
dont on sait que le marché est saturé et
un extrêmement attention donc voila nous
on a un certain nombre de questions
assez précises au delà de cette date qui
est importante encore une fois c'est
vrai que le confinement pèse notamment
aux secteurs les plus vulnérables dans
les plus précaires de la population mais
je pense plus largement il ya beaucoup
de souffrances et de difficultés
physiques émotionnels psychologiques
dans cette période est donc il me semble
que cette cette intervention
au delà de la date du 11 mai manqué et
manque de précision et j'espère en tous
les cas que le président et son
gouvernement vont cette fois privilégier
la protection sanitaire de la population
et non l'économie puisque c'est bien une
des raisons pour lesquelles nous sommes
rentrés tardivement confinement parce
que il y avait ce primat de de
l'économie l'activité économique c'est
aussi pour ça que certains secteurs sont
encore en activité parce qu'il faut
privilégier l'activité économique
donc nous allons être vigilants pour
cette ces prochaines semaines et ces
prochaines phases pour que avant tout
c'est la santé de la population
son bien-être physique son bien-être
social
qui prime sur sur la volonté de profits
à petit prix danièle obono on assister
un petit mea culpa si j'ose dire des
manuels micron qui a commencé par dire à
l'évidence la france n'était pas prête
il a terminé également par voilà un
discours un peu plus lyrique sachons
nous réinventer moi le premier ça veut
dire selon vous que le président de la
république a été changée par cette
épreuve et va peut-être assouplir sa
politique notamment envers les personnes
peut-être les plus défavorisés ce qu'on
lui a souvent reproché à côté trop
libérale est ce qu'il va changer selon
vous
je ne le crois pas franchement surtout
les premiers à appuyer une véritable
réorientation c'est ce que nous avons
dit y compris dès le départ que ces
crises signé l'échec de l'ensemble des
politiques néolibérales anti social et
anti écologique qui ont été menées ces
dernières années et notamment par
emmanuel macron qui est dans
l'institution au pouvoir depuis des
années et qu'il fallait dès maintenant
dans la manière dont nous mettions en
oeuvre y compris la planification y
compris l'organisation et la mise en
action de la société il fallait dès
maintenant réorienter bifurquer faire en
sorte par exemple que l'enjeu écologique
ne passe pas à la trappe par volonté
absolue de faire repartir l'économie et
du coup de faire repartir sur des bases
productiviste et cetera
mais justement ce que fait aujourd'hui
le gouvernement ça montre précisément
qu'il n'a toujours pas retenu la leçon
des raisons pour lesquelles nous sommes
dans une crise sanitaire et économique
notamment l'état des services publics
hospitaliers et on le voit comme je l'aï
dit tout à l'heure avec la volonté de
faire travailler à tout prix des
secteurs non essentiels qui ne servent
ni à apporter des moyens pour le soin
des personnes ou à la prévention aux as
alimentation et les secteurs essentiels
on le voit avec les discours qui appelle
à faire des efforts mais pas de tout le
monde et certainement pas des plus
riches
et puis on le voit avec la manière dont
on le fait dans sur sur le terrain c'est
avant tout la stigmatisation et une
politique plus de répression et de et 2
et 2 et sécuritaire qui est mise en
oeuvre pourquoi il faut je crois à
rester mobilisés et et préparés nous
mêmes dès maintenant l'alternative le
président honorables en plis nou lé
message merci danièle obono en tout cas
d'avoir réagi en direct sur arte france